good morning believe nation today's
message is know what you really want
over the new Alan Watson Paul said that
the labourer is worthy of his hire and I
as a philosopher mere philosopher no
dealing in higher things always insists
that I be paid for my work and I get the
highest fee I can get and people say
well you're just out for money I say
there's none of your business because I
give most of it away my own needs being
extremely simple although I enjoy good
food I don't even own a television set
and you know it's a very simple life but
I've got enough and enough is as good as
a feast you see a lot of people don't
feel happy unless they have another
thing beyond money which is called
status and status to a very large extent
in our economy consists in conspicuous
consumption in having this thing and
that thing and the other thing in having
a swimming pool a Ferrari certain kind
of clothes and some kind of house with
an enormous round style picture window
and so on and so on and so on and we
think we need all that because we've
been persuaded by a certain kind of
propaganda that that's how we ought to
live because we haven't asked ourselves
whether that was what we really wanted
in other words we've been propagandized
into thinking what we wanted I think a
lot of people in entrepreneurship are
being sold a pipe dream I think a lot of
the videos a lot of people talking
entrepreneurship we're talking about the
entrepreneur lifestyle where all you
want are Ferraris and private jets and
Islands and all of the things that money
combine the path to do that is
entrepreneurship and and it's easy to
buy into that it's easy to spend money
on courses and program but it's a lie if
you look at the people who has the most
success in entrepreneurship none of them
has that as their ambition none of the
people you look up to have massive
success in any industry started with a
dream board a vision board of having a
Ferrari on it if that is your goal you
will never get there the most successful
entrepreneurs have an absolute passion
for changing the way something is done
in their industry so you have to tap
into what that is otherwise you're going
to fail it's like looking at LeBron
James and seeing this guy who has a lot
of money
who's driving nice cars who's wearing
nice clothes like I want the LeBron
James lifestyle I want to look like I
want to dress like that guy I want I
want to be the man like LeBron James
when I walk off an airplane and I'm all
pimped out in the latest - that's what I
want to be like how did LeBron James get
there by working his face off by caring
about the game of basketball and by
going all-in on that if you look at
basketball as a way just to make money
and look like LeBron James you will
never put in the work to actually be
great at basketball because that's not
what you care about
LeBron doesn't care about the suits
LeBron cares about winning championships
and the suits are nice byproduct of it
you get the difference LeBron doesn't
care about just getting the next Ferrari
in his collection or buying the next
shoe that comes out those are nice perks
so that those are bad but it's not the
ultimate goal the goal is win
championships that's what you have to be
olena if you want to be successful so
equate that back to your business if you
are starting to business just to achieve
a yacht and a Ferrari and a private
island on your vision board you're not
going to get there because you won't put
in the work you have to want to win
championships or whatever that
equivalent is
your industry you want to stomp in your
industry and the side benefit of all of
that is the cars is the material wealth
is whatever you want but it can't be
number one so it encourage you to
dramatically reevaluate where your
priorities are and until you set them
straight you're never going to achieve
where you have the potential to achieve
so the question of a today is I'm
curious what is the equivalent of
winning championship rings in your
industry what does that look like for
you leave in the comments below I'm
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to David
MSN David thank you so much you're
picking up a cup of my book your one
word really means a lot to me man I hope
you're enjoying the read and you're
applying it to your life in your
business I appreciate the support thank
you guys again for watching I hope you
have an amazing day I believe in you and
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events better
[Music]
I think people need to get sit-down and
clarify what experiences are you really
looking for in your life and that
doesn't necessarily mean it can include
lots of money but it can also include
what do you want to experience with that
money a sense of freedom a sense of
service a sense of providing value to
the world a sense of self confidence and
self efficacy what is it that you're
after so there's you know in my own you
know explorations and the whole personal
growth and self-awareness beyond game
for years I've been involved in that
pretty seriously you know there's an
exercise and say well what do you want I
want to read Portia great what
experience do you think that's going to
give you freedom in a sense of fun
whatever and other people get the red
Porsche and they're worried about
somebody going to Dennett and they you
know they can't afford the payments on
it they didn't really get the experience
they were looking for what happened they
got the they got the symbol but they
didn't get the inner experience but if
you want the experience of freedom and
fun you can have that this afternoon
doesn't mean you shouldn't have the red
Porsche but it just means that if you
start to focus on the inner experience
what would climbing the corporate ladder
give you as an inner experience why do
you want that what's important to you
about that it could be it could be I
want to I want to provide you know for
my family for you know for after I'm
gone so there's a sense of building
wealth or building net worth of building
assets you know for the people around
you that care that matters
that's there's no right or wrong about
any of your answers to this but I think
getting clear about whether you want to
do that or whether you want to get there
because you want to be able to impact a
much larger segment of the world for
doing good or taking it over I don't
know for what do you know whatever you
want but I think that's the key is being
able to externalize and start to become
objective about well what is it that
you're after
and so just crafting your own ideal
scene not only of the things you want
which is fine don't don't stop that now
if I don't feel embarrassed that you
want a red Porsche so there's nothing
wrong with any of that material stuff
that you might want but it's also true
that it's a real good idea to just say
let me just play it that all out and
then use that as a map just to then
guide you in terms of your intuitive
decision-making
I don't think you have to work at it
that hard but I think you do need to be
conscious about it and
validated in some part of yourself the
difference between people who are
successful or not or the those who are
successful seem to know from age of
seven or eight maybe older you know
they're very in tune with what they love
they compared to a voice inside their
head not literally a voice but something
saying you you really are drawn to this
subject and they hear it throughout
their lives for me it was it was writing
and books since I was a kid and you know
anytime I deviated from that love and
went into something else I just was so
unhappy I knew that I wasn't doing the
right thing and so it's just like this
voice that keeps drawing you back to
what you really really love well I would
say I've always believed that a strong
mission statements really important and
I had to say we've never succeeded at it
it's like this odd thing you know we've
had them every year for 15 years and
they're constantly grown and now we're
all so cynical we're like come off we're
trying to make people happy I mean
that's the fundamental thing is in
consumer service you know we're trying
to be better and us in Disney and
mission aren't that different there's a
bunch of different tactics at it but
we're an emotional product we cater to
the things that are important but not
necessary and I love that part about it
because like when you're selling milk or
penicillin you're selling something
somebody needs and we get to sell
something you want okay that you choose
to do because it's really cool a human
and how to be entertained and connect to
people over entertainment and so we
celebrate that a lot and we want to
change the industry but in terms of like
a mission statement like so many
companies have you know Facebook talks
about a more connected and open world
and then you see that phrase again and
again and again and it's a powerful
mantra we don't have an equivalent and I
think we probably would have been
stronger if we do in the early days it
was to connect people with movies they
loved and it's okay but it's kind of
like a long kind of awkward phrase
connect people with movies they love and
you know it's just not punchy and and
then
like we used it we had t-shirts you know
and then I didn't really motivate anyone
didn't really stick but we knew we were
trying to make people happy with DVDs
and then eventually was dreaming an
original content